so i wonder how many of you have any
kind of memory
of this diagram it was a whole you know
in 2020 that year which we'd all like to
be repressing from our memories right
now
we went quite a ways through the topic
of complex numbers before i pulled this
one out it wasn't complete at the time
by the way
do you remember it actually had a bunch
of white boxes over some sections
because i was like
hey we've met a bunch of these ideas and
they will go further in
and we're going to explore everything
that this
imaginary unit i unlocks for us and it
was quite a lot
right now i want you to recall and it's
down here
do you wanna maybe yeah i usually we
love the fresh air but maybe not if it's
going to blow anyone over
i wonder if you remember down here in
the bottom right hand corner
right we started to explore some
important
ideas because we began with a complex
number
as a horizontal vertical coordinate so
rectangular form
but then we went into mod arg form do
you remember that we also called it
polar form
trigonometric form and of course what we
were really laying the foundation for
modulus argument what we were really
laying the foundation for
was numbers which have both direction
and
magnitude right of course that's not how
it's actually said but
i i can't i can't do it jason's eagle
impressions so
we we reference briefly hey are there
these things called vectors they can be
very useful
for you to geometrically think about
these objects complex numbers
but then we said okay let's move on now
right let's go back into the rest of
that complex number world
polynomials demarcus serum you recall
okay
and then where did you pick up from
there in extension one you've been doing
vectors and projection and dot products
and all that kind of thing okay
now within extension two and you can
make this heading now if you like we're
gonna extend that work
into three dimensions
three dimensional vectors
now it is worth saying from the outset
that a lot of what you learned
in two dimensional vectors it's just
going to carry forward you're going to
learn about
coordinate systems and dot products and
project all that kind of stuff
will be consistent it's just like well
we just
put them on steroids now you've got
extra unit vectors to worry about right
so conceptually
a lot of that will feel familiar however
i know that from when i learned this
it was quite a cognitive load actually
just to go from two dimensions to three
despite the fact that we all live
in three dimensions the mathematics of
it is actually quite complicated so
today what we're going to do
is just get our minds into the frame of
thinking
in three dimensions which i know sounds
strange because like i said we live in
them but
how do we represent this go ahead and
draw yourself a cartesian plane
you might notice i've only got a quarter
of a cartesian plane here and you'll see
why
in a second in order to go from
a cartesian plane to a
3d coordinate system that's very similar
to our cartesian plane
we have this huge limitation which is
that the
things we're going to work with in the
space we're working within is well
mostly for all of us i'm pretty sure
flat right it's a two-dimensional object
that you're going to be drawing
three-dimensional things
on okay so we want to make sure we lay
our groundwork and our foundations
really really firmly because we're going
to build a heck of a lot on it okay
here's the first mind twist x and y
we're very used to think you have as
horizontal and vertical
okay but in three dimensions you can
think about this in many different ways
but there's a conventional way you're
going to see
more uh often than anything else and
here's how it's going
to look pens out of hands eyes up for a
second and just watch carefully what's
going to happen to my x y plane
the conventional way for representing
three dimensions
the conventional way not the only way
but the conventional way
is to take this x y plane and imagine
placing it flat on the ground okay which
is kind of nice for you because you're
like well mine mine is flat
on a table right so you can see x is now
coming toward you
as it were and then y is heading up
there so if you imagine sort of standing
over it
but from this side right that's why y
used to be up
do you see from where i'm standing y is
going up as it were okay
now if that's where x and y are on a
flat horizontal plane
where is z going to go and you can see
based on where i put this
you can point your finger in the right
direction right it's going to go
up so the conventional way that we would
think of the new
z-axis is that's our new up y used to be
up
but now z is up okay go ahead and beside
your cartesian plane
draw yourself one of these okay
now this is part of the reason why by
the way i only drew a quarter
of the cartesian plane before i could
have done all four quadrants
but when you go into three dimensions
starts to get a bit trickier
now i'm just going to borrow my board
for a second we will get to this on the
computer shortly but
if you have this thing
going off into your three directions and
you imagine these
continuing like at the moment i've just
got the positive x-axis the positive
y-axis
and the positive z-axis as you move
into negative x and
negative y and negative
z our 3d space is not divided into
four quadrants it's actually divided
into now
think about it for a second think about
what would be the equivalent
of a quadrant in this three
dimensions i'm just going to give you a
clue i'm showing you only one of them
right now only one quadrant is visible
positive positive positive
x y and z they're actually not quadrants
at all because there's not
four how many sections have i divided up
3d space into can you see them
i've actually done counter eight right
if you think about it this way i'm
actually just going to go backwards
right if you think about
we have the xy plane right and then when
you put it flat
on the ground it's still now dividing
into four if i had the negative parts as
well do you agree with that
so there's just four and then what i do
when i put z through it is
now there's a top and a bottom there's a
top
four and a bottom four so instead of
calling them quadrants because that
would give you
four what's our prefix to do with
eight oct so these are called
octants right you've got eight octants
that are represented i've only just
shown you
one of them okay now we need to get a
better handle
on this and as you can see i've been
working with this flat space and it's
quite tricky so what i'm going to try
and do
is put you into three dimensions now i
highly encourage you in the same way
that mrs liz and i frequently use desmos
to do lots of functions and graphing and
geometry with you
if you want to work in three dimensions
geogebra
is where you want to go okay and if you
just google maybe you want to drop this
down now
3d geogebra you'll turn up this tool if
you just do regular geodra it starts out
in 2d
we want to start out in 3d okay
so here's the same kind of thing uh red
is x
green is y blue is z so far same thing
that we had over here
let's add in our other direction so
let's go
with let's put in the negative
x can you see what i've just put in
there right it's going into the screen
whereas x positive x was coming out at
you
okay you can see if i now put on let's
get y
it's going to go to the left where
positive y was going to the right
and then lastly where's positive or
rather negative z going to go
it's going to go down because you drew
you told me to draw positive z
up so of course negative z would be down
okay
now this leads to a bunch of
implications
for example um if you have a think about
uh let's uh let's go back to our
cartesian plan you've got your cartesian
plane still there
right do you have them separate you've
got the two okay really simple trivial
thing
humor me okay on this cartesian plane
can you please draw for me x equals five
x equals five what does that look like
and in fact once you've drawn it can you
hold it up for me just so i've
got an indication of how many of you
have it ready if you had your cartesian
plane there this should take all of two
seconds okay i've got one i've got come
on hold him up i've got one so far out
of
hold up a bit closer for me okay i've
got something there good
fantastic all right hold him up a bit
higher for me
interesting interesting okay thank you
hands down
our books down rather all right this is
actually not entirely what i expected i
got about a 50 50 split
several of you have done this
i've drawn that as x equals five now i
don't disagree
don't disagree i don't disagree that
that is x equals five
however i would say a more accurate way
of saying this is that's x equals five
on a number
line do you agree on a number line
there's only one
one and only one place that can claim
the name x equals five
but on the plane there's a whole bunch
of places
that can say i'm x equals five where
else can you go
it can go up and down right in fact x
equals five if you haven't included this
already
is this whole vertical line okay
what does x equals five i've already
kind of
flagged it by saying this is what it is
on a number line this is what it is on
another plane
what would it look like x equals five in
three
dimensions what do you think calvin
if we go up in dimensions right here's
my um
think about this for a second this point
it's a zero dimensional object
on a one-dimensional space stay with me
it's a bit weird right
this line is a one-dimensional object in
a two-dimensional space
yes x equals five
is a two dimensional space
sorry yes in in a three dimensional
space does that make sense
everything on that let's rotate this
route so you can see it a bit more
easily
everything on that sheet on that surface
can say my x value is five right
the y value can change which is why i
can move now across the green direction
my z value can change which is why i can
go up and down in the blue direction
okay but i'm only locked in at x equals
five and of course
as you change whatever value you want
you're moving your plane back and forth
in the x direction make sense just like
if i change this to x equals four three
two one
you'd be moving it in the x direction
yeah
okay this is really important because
some of the language we've been using in
2d vectors
comes into here right have a think about
this if i say
i've got x equals five
what's its relationship there's this
very particular word that you learnt
in 2d vectors that rene relates the x
equals five
line to the x axis what's the word
starts with an o
it's a new word orthogonal is our fancy
extension one word for what word would
we have used in like u seven and eight
to describe these two
lines orthogonal means
perpendicular right now the reason why
we introduced this new word orthogonal
is because perpendicular
strictly is only speaking about lines
you can only have a line
and another line perpendicular to each
other and orthogonality is about what if
you have other things
like you know surfaces and planes right
so this is the important thing and you
need to have this and this is going to
be tricky i know but
this you want to try and represent on
your diagram right here's my x equals 5
plane in exactly the same way that the x
equals 5
line is perpendicular to the x-axis
the x equals 5 plane is
orthogonal do you see it i've tried to
draw that right angle in black right
it's orthogonal to the x-axis are you
with me
now i was at uni when i first discovered
the word orthogonal it wasn't in the
syllabus before
and i remember puzzling over it and not
really ever understanding what it meant
and i literally mrs lee's actually saw
it maybe heard it happen
earlier today it only just now clicks
for me why this word is what it is
is anyone here obsessed with etymology
like where words come from anyone
okay i hope you're going to benefit out
of this okay orthogonal
that suffix gone right
where have you seen that before in
geometry what words end in
gone shapes right like
polygons pentagons hexagons
octagons not quatigons but anyway you
get the idea right
the gone means angle that's what that
means right
now i don't know how many of you are
like me and that you have
or had braces i had braces
hands up if you ever had or still have
braces hands up straight
okay fewer you i'm glad for the majority
of you who have never experienced this
okay
as the people with their hands up no not
the most fun experience but
all of you who raise your hands and
maybe those of you who didn't can tell
me
who's the person you see to get braces
put in
it's an orthodontist right
what's an orthodontist's job their job
is to get your teeth your dentition your
dental things
to get them right because they're all
weird and jagged and in the wrong spot
and i actually fun fact
i had a tooth coming out of the roof of
my mouth like right out of the middle
and i said to my mum when i was 12 i was
like
mum there's a tooth coming out of the
middle of my mouth and she's like
no there's not and i was like no really
and six months later i said mom this
tooth is getting really big and she
she looked and she's like well you have
a tooth coming out of your mouth and i
was like i know and
orthodontists fixed that they got my
teeth
right so tell me please tell me what
does
orthogonal actually just mean
right angled that's all it means okay